you guys know that Black Mirror episode
where they have the ratings it's my
favorite episode
uh you know that woman starts off at a
very high rating and watches her rating
plummet
and
at the end she has the one star and
she's in jail and she's just screaming
and she feels so liberated
this is what I feel
I feel you know like like the gpts have
made it so obvious that it's all
all of the niceties and
language and all of the oh yes I'm going
to write a four paragraph email to
express a two-sentence idea
is it over is the professional
managerial class over
I heard the Barbie movie described last
night as post-woke and I thought that
was really cool
uh okay my talk is called three stories
and we have three stories one about the
past one about the future and one about
the present
uh so we will jump right into the first
story about the past with the crude is
automation
um
so Cruise automation most people don't
know this right most people see the
weird orange hat branding today and like
look we're building cars that are
symmetrical I don't even get it but uh
you know Kyle was actually uh first
building the cruise rp1 Highway
autopilot for ten thousand dollars
and it sat on top of your car like that
assuming your car was an Audi A4 uh and
it worked on the highway uh to drive
um so Lex was guest 14. uh Kyle was
guest 14 on Lex
and he gave up due to the technical
challenge
um he didn't give up because it was a
bad idea it's actually the right idea
he gave up because it was too hard and
he had three concrete complaints about
why it was too hard
one is that there's a long tail of cars
right so uh they built it for the Audi
A4 we're like okay we can make it work
on the Audi S4 maybe the A6 and you
realize that almost no one drives Audis
all right we started with an Acura look
I made the same mistake
um and it turns out there's this
absurdly long tail of cars
uh
so how do you deal with this
well you just do it that's not that much
work
comes a 20-person company and we just
did it thanks to you know contributors
thank you contributors but like it's
doable right you just do it okay cool
oh but but how do you handle failures
what if a car has a sensor that fails or
GPS that fails or a camera that fails or
steering wheel thing that fails steering
wheel actuator uh okay you just do it
um open pilot has a great error
detection and handling system the alerts
uh Alex Roy drove in a car with a comma
one and this is what he praised he's
like wow this thing actually like
communicates with you
um so hopefully you guys have
experienced that using open pilot like
it actually
you know gives you errors that tell you
what's going on
then we track all of these on a back-end
dashboard and we drive them down to zero
um so again you just have to do it uh
it's different in one version of the car
what if the car manufacturer updates the
firmware
okay
you do it
fingerprinting
yeah
we'll read all the firmware versions
we'll figure out which ones matter we'll
figure out which ones don't we'll do
this at scale
right these things are engineering
challenges
fake any of them either
when you ship a product to people you
can't fake any of this stuff
all right that's probably mostly of open
pilot you guys probably mostly have
common threes and it works in your car
and it handles failures
it deals with all the different versions
of the car you just have to do it
common was not supposed to exist
there is no sane reason that this
company should exist
the second round when we raised from
Adrian Horowitz
I pitched him a crypto coin
hey look man you want to hear I'm
telling you what you want to hear man
I'll tell you what you want to hear I
know they're but you know you
want to hear it finals I'll tell you
that I know enough about crypto to make
it sound convincing
um our third round we raised from much
more aligned investors
uh look and it's not that even that
Andreessen Horowitz is bad it's just
that like again you have to think about
what these people are optimizing for and
what time Horizon they're thinking on
usually very short time Horizons
um so but then again you ask yourself
what's what's worth doing in the world
there's another scene from Back to the
Future too
if you're not building a company that
looks like that line what are you doing
with your life right
if if the only thing that's going to be
different if you succeed with your
company this is to everyone in the
audience everyone out there watching if
the only thing that's going to be
different is that the pile of money is
in your entry in the SQL database
instead of somebody else's
why are you doing this bro it doesn't
matter just update the SQL database it's
a lot easier
um so yeah you know build companies that
look like that companies that are going
to change the future
not change the distribution of wealth in
the future
all right
I'm not doing this to like we'll get to
that this is a story about the past
so here we are
six generations of the hardware
zero
whatever you play with the letters a bit
comma two comma three I love when
Hardware companies just do that just
make the number bigger every time so you
know right it's easy
um
yeah
that's it
250 plus cars
uh every major brand except for the Flex
Pay ones Mercedes BMW no but otherwise
with Ford that's all of them
25 employees
uh uh an open source
all right so uh I think it's pretty easy
for us to tell that all three of those
numbers are going to go up begrudgingly
on the third one very happily on the
first two
um
and open source will stay uh keep you
want Hardware to be good look at the
iPhone right this is iPhone 13. you know
why it's good because they built like 13
other ones they built even more
all right that's how you make something
good you just keep doing it you just
iterate it ship it you iterate on it
uh you want to support more cars okay
make sure you don't have regressions
well we'll get that I mean how how do we
how do we do this right
let's start with some like
that one
right did you hear helion energy is
going to ship a fusion power to the grid
by 2028. did you hear Cruz is going to
have a billion dollars in Revenue by
like can I bet against these things it's
fake
I hope that every
you've got like a real sense of honesty
and part of the reason you get honesty
here is because we don't have
communications people what are
Communications people in a company
besides paid Liars right what is the job
of it what is the job of a press
secretary
oh oh okay you you murdered 30 orphans
in Cuba uh I make it look good though
make it look good right
no like it was just honesty and it's
honestly because lying if you tell the
truth you don't have to remember
anything
you know that's that's a good quote
right
um
tripping
you had a ship shipping keeps you honest
all right your ship stuff you send it
out to people and they'll tell you about
whether it's crap or not you know how
they'll tell you you know there's two
types of ways to measure people's
preferences your stated preference and
revealed preference right stated
preference is things people say they
want like
well wouldn't it be nice if we had cars
where we could share the car so we could
uh save the environment and then you
look at the HOV lanes on highways and
the usage of uber pool and you're like
wait a second no no no no no no no
everyone wants their own car right
reveal preference beat stated preference
so how do we measure reveal preference
we sell something
profitably
and then see who buys it all right
so I'm shipping
iteration
uh you know how you build something good
you build it bad three other times right
and that one's still not that good you
know that one is bad after you get to
the one that's built three times later
and there's no way around this the only
thing you can control is your iteration
speed right how quickly can you iterate
how quickly can you come out with new
versions how can you reduce the rebel
time but you have to iterate
um and then the last one is humility
oh yeah you know this guy used to call
me Eagle hot you know it's kind of funny
right I do have a big ego I think I'm
better than a lot of people I mean
that's a true fact right I think I'm
better than a lot of people now look
Google you may disagree with me about
that fact and I'm open to having a
conversation about it I'm open to you
know what do you want to what do you
wanna what what shall we challenge each
other at right
but that's not what humility means right
that's like like acting humility is
saying
okay there's an actual problem how are
we going to solve it right like it's
humility not as some status game but
humility in the real face of nature how
do you solve these problems well you
have to have humility you know it turns
out you think you think oh well I'll
train the machine learning model it'll
work you know I thought this is a
comment I'm like well I'll put in the
I'll put in the output path and I'll put
the image in and it'll work this turns
out to not work at all
um you can look up behavioral cloning or
imitation learning for why it doesn't
work and you just got to have humility
you know what I mean like Nature Nature
Nature doesn't care nature doesn't care
you know and it's humility versus nature
not humility versus people uh so yeah
you know you got some get some values of
a company right
um all right
so why haven't we won
do we have the right right
we could talk about what I'm doing wrong
talk about what we're doing wrong but
why haven't we won
um and then the truth is things take a
long time even accounting for things
taking a long time
this is not the first Comic-Con this
will not be the last Comic-Con
all right humans live a long time you
know this is something a lot of people
forget about in the world today like a
lot of people are so like man how can I
get rich quick how can I pull this scam
how can I ship fusion power to the grid
by 2020 bro you can't even ship fishing
power to the grid by 2028.
you know
um so
yeah I'm gonna look I'm 33. I'm gonna be
here for a while
all right so you start thinking about
that I'm not trying to get rich I'm not
trying to retire there is no exit
there's no exit
okay you know what books are no egg this
is no exit this is it this is it hell is
other people right like
like there is no well we're gonna get to
this point and then we're gonna stop no
the system is going to get better and
the system is going to get relentlessly
better
right it's Comic-Con too we'll see this
is about the past
oh
think about like climbing out of a well
um so let's you know put it yeah all
right
how long is it going to take to solve
cell traffic
no idea
but as long as every day
you make forward progress as long as
every day you make a few steps climbing
to get out of the well and as long as at
night you don't slide backwards
As Long as You Follow That algorithm you
are eventually going to get out of the
well
right avoid regressions and make slow
and continuous Improvement this is how
you make things good
so climbing out of a well there's not
another way to do it
no but you don't understand we're going
to get a huge cash infusion
no
it's not going to get you out of the
well man what are you going to do you
got a number in a SQL database right
it turns out these companies are scams
right
well this is Aurora too simple luminar
they all raise way more money than comma
dead
which
uh oh none of these are Fusion these are
all self-driving cars and lidar but okay
so it's it's question right what does it
mean for something to be a scam
there's something to be a scam require
Awareness on the part of the creator
that it's a scam
right if the answer to that is no if you
believe that intention matters
then what you're going to get is honest
idiots to raise billions of dollars
right they're being honest but they are
idiots right
this was obvious to me I've been saying
this exact same thing now for seven
years
I could have told you
I did tell you but I'll listen right
you know people also thought that
bitconnect and Luna warrant scams
right there's people honestly out there
who chilled me both of those products
right and now I mean look both of their
Founders are in jail so you know we can
all like there's a spectrum of scams
right
but um
yeah
uh you know we'll get the cruising
windmill later
marginal utility approaches marginal
costs is a true theorem of economics and
what is the marginal cost of open pilot
it's the marginal cost of open pilot
zero right so if open power provides any
utility at all marginal utility
approaches marginal costs a lot of times
you don't want to measure success in
value creation because a lot of value
creation is a scam look at GDP
kind of want to measure success and
value destruction if you can destroy
fake moats of companies open pilot will
continue to get better open pilot will
solve self-driving cars and open pilot
will be free
[Applause]
[Music]
did you know Linux is the fastest
growing platform on azure
it's not just a smart guy and Bryce
right and Bryce the car companies that
are smart will embrace the car companies
that are not smart will ship you the Sun
Cloud or the Oracle cloud or whatever
Cloud you know oracle still exists I
don't know how they make money but
whatever
um Linux is the fastest growing platform
in Azure markets do approach rationality
you just have to survive
Market can remain you know irrational
longer than you can remain solvent uh
yeah
yeah this is a lifetime Revenue comma
nice uh nice R of like that something
uh this is the amount these companies
have made in lifetime Revenue versus the
amount they've raised
no like I don't get it I don't I don't
know man maybe I didn't go to Harvard or
get an MBA or something
but like bro well okay look man look man
we we raised we raised 3 700 million
dollars and we made 200. okay that's
cool man
like
I don't get it I don't like I I would
I'm not even saying like Okay obviously
would you first raise for a company this
is true but these aren't recent raises
but these companies have raised after
they were not even remotely close to
making back their initial investment in
Revenue not profit Revenue right you can
look at other companies like Amazon and
Uber and be like well I mean Uber's
hilariously unprofitable but they make a
lot of Revenue they have a lot of users
these companies don't
uh so this is the number for comma
uh 22.2 on 18.1 million raised
there's Twitter followers for all right
I told you I'd address cruising waymo
right so I actually do honestly believe
that Cruz and waymo have larger
marketing budgets than the operating
budget of comma
right and uh soon man soon all right
look they use a linear model but like
this is what the website said so
uh
employee retention uh four people have
ever quit over seven years
uh
it turns out honesty is a great draw uh
same Mission folks governance a
commitment to iteration and Improvement
I'll come work here
uh
look all this stuff everything about
opioid I didn't do any of it
I haven't I haven't pushed to commit to
open Pile in two years that's everyone
else you saw talk here today you'll saw
me
um my sole job is to keep idiots far
away right that's really that's really
my only job right like it turns out yeah
I promised the other parts are more
upbeat the past is always depressing you
know but
uh no seriously um
to anyone watching this to anyone in the
audience if you want to come work here
look the bar is really high but what we
ship hopefully is really good and you'll
get to ship things right you'll get to
ship things you'll get to be a part of
this process that makes things better in
the world
and I think that's the real thing
especially as we approach this like
everyone late stage capitalism everyone
kind of understands the economies
whatever man fugazi right
uh I think the thing that people really
want is that they want to make the world
a better place like I said if your
startup looks like this
you know you're just changing the
distribution but if you start it looks
like this you're changing the world
I did not realize I was entering such a
dishonest game I have never seen a more
wretched Hive of scum and villainy that
I have in the business worlds
uh but you know we're gonna win anyway
just takes a lot more out of you than
you think it's gone
okay
the future
I'm excited about the future
I really am
so we'll start with a nice quote from uh
Eli Isaac goodkowski
and I'll plug in the numbers for the
current computing speeds the current
doubling time and estimate for the raw
processing power of the human brain and
the numbers matching 2021.
interesting
not not that far off
and I think we have a little bit of
still work to do on the software but
like
everyone kind of sees it right
like this is a lot easier I've been I've
been talking about this stuff man when I
read when I read this quote when I was
15. it's changed my life my whole life
my entire life trajectory has pretty
much been because of you know this guy
in this document I'm sure he incredibly
disadvous it right now we got to Nuke
the data centers don't forget but um no
really uh
yeah
so what is the future
I'm going to tell a little story and my
story is called forward-looking
statement
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
Comic-Con 9 it is the year 2037. I am an
AI generated voice hiring real people to
do Pas became
way too expensive in the early 30s
um
you've grown quite a bit since the first
Comic-Con in 2021
we have 44 stores and malls around the
world
excessive and a billion devices sold
in the top 10 biggest consumer
electronics companies and we did without
selling out
um so let's look at a picture of a mall
this is a real Mall you guys should all
take it out while you're here it's
definitely uh it's called the UTC Mall
uh and I'm serious about the mall store
like like it's written on our boys
inside like come on isn't this where you
want to buy a commentary isn't this
where you want to buy a common body
you know like come by the mall store
oh The Meta versus lame it's gonna be a
real Mall store go get a Cinnabon no one
has said about anymore get a bubble tea
Happy Lemon
um so we're gonna we're gonna have a
store in the mall uh yeah
that's gonna happen is more stories real
uh it's hard to go anywhere without
finding a comma remember it's 20 37.
in its three form factors cars bodies
and puppies it is versatile enough
for everything
you'll find commas transporting goods
cleaning houses cooking meals and just
being a lovable companion that will go
anywhere with you
it's not rendered
uh uh yeah
now announcing become a seven
just two twenty that many dollars they
have to be twenty twenty three dollars
look I don't control the inflation
uh the third generation comma Asic
uh 50 pops of compute that's fifty
thousand Tera UPS
uh for reference the comma 3 has about
five
factor of ten thousand don't worry don't
worry the future comes fast slowly and
then quickly
um it's the first Common device to boot
into tiny grab
well no really like look at on pilot
right like open pilot is kind of this
open pilot right now kind of means two
things right it's kind of both this
system layer and the self-drive layer
right the self-drive layer is a policy
model for driving on on roads these
system layer is like a camera Damon
maybe we'll even start to move things
like the vision model into the system
layer right but you have this system
layer in open pilot which runs
Foundation models
right and then you have on top of that a
policy model which does driving and then
underneath that you have tiny grab you
have an operating system which can run
all these models and schedule them
appropriately
50 pops is a magical number combined
with the latest version of open pilot
our foundation models learned in the
cloud RL in the world and a good amount
of on device learning we expect a comma
7 to be able to do anything a human can
do
this does not stop at self-driving cars
okay
level four level five this doesn't like
this is boring
oh but but I heard the question before
not to call not to not to not to pick on
you like oh like like why don't you
focus in on like an application oh my
God
I'm trying to build people
we're trying to build people that's what
we're trying to build here
right
self-driving is just a really cool it's
kind of a restrictive problem right you
can refine your techniques in
self-driving it's like a game but
eventually
this all becomes general purpose and
sooner than you might think right I was
trolling you know when we do the Taco
Bell challenge i i i Elon replied to one
of my things and I was like yo
our system is going to be so end to end
that even our DM's going to be end to
end
you guys saw it
uh yeah
anything a human can do is an
interesting thing too right so this is
my 300 this is what we build the uh
comma threes on
you understand that it's being operated
Now by a comma seven right
you understand that most of the
employees in the company now are commas
right
it's interesting right I mean how many
of our and you'll hear about this in a
later talk today how many of our workers
how many people worth of compute does
comma have if you define a person as 20
petaflops you'll get an answer to that
later today
right
how many how many silicon people work at
the company
I'm not here to discriminate man I'm a
progressive
and I'm saying yeah no I mean it was
crazy when we first saw comma 7 actually
come over and like help build the other
comma sevens it was it was a wild uh
your comma seven is yours just like your
comma 3 is yours
the models we train in the cloud are
Foundation models meaning they do not
have opinions they're not rlhft they are
true foundation models and I want to
give a thank you even though I lost 80
000 in your stock and really regret
selling it I want to give a thank you to
meta for releasing llama 2 as the
foundation model and not just the rlhf
version we want to do the same
and
I will
whatever it takes there's no cause I
believe in more than open source AI
um so the models we train in the cloud
are Foundation models they do not have
opinions
we do offer some pre-trained policy
models we call them custom software
maybe some of you are familiar with that
right if you want a custom if you want a
pre-trained policy model that drives a
car again how it drives the car is is a
decision right we make some decisions
about how to drive right but that's
that's when you get into opinions right
foundation models are unsupervised
trained policy models are trained
supervised in some way shape or form
with Samara Al with some supervised with
whatever but by default the uh comma
seven is like a child
it will learn whatever behaviors you
teach it so teach it well
and it should pick up skills as quickly
as a smart human
what's that
uh yeah I don't really know what's next
the comma 8 will likely be running the
company
let's look at it for a minute right
it's got two eyes
it's got a mouth
it breathesis air
it has two ears I've pushed hard to keep
those two ears
it has a spinal cord
is it a spinal cord
I mean yeah all right look it's a comma
three it's got this looks like a little
bird brain right it looks like one of
them dumb dinosaurs you know
but we'll get there we'll get there
robotics is all a question of
intelligence
all right
turned out how many of you guys have
robot vacuums they're pretty good now
right
how many of the meat courts
all right a lot of the e chords because
they're not smart enough to really
understand and like the comma 3 is about
the same intelligence as a b right it's
not as smart as a mouse never mind a dog
or a human but we'll get there
robotics
and that's like humans are so good at
like moving we are so dexterous with our
hands people forget like how good humans
are
people forget how good humans are
driving they have all this self-driving
rhetoric oh the cars are going to be
safer or nothing I haven't seen a car
that's anywhere near as safe
right now ital systems can make it safer
because as systems you pay attention at
all times I do believe that ADA systems
make it safer But A system that
completely takes control away from the
human
you're forgetting how good humans are
humans are really good and humans are
good because they're intelligence
they're intelligent robotics is all
question tones
but now back to the present
it's 2023 and you are Comic-Con too
thank you all for coming out
uh I hope I hope the things you saw
today were good
Mall store
all right come on I really I really went
off in the weeds of the future if at the
mall store is going to happen soon right
the monster is going to happen soon
all right all right I love it all right
uh in the present huh yeah
a present clip art
all right
um I'm gonna sit here for a minute
so we can all decompress a little about
the future because we're we're really
about to undergo a major tone shift in
the presentation
the next slide is a is a major tone
shift from this hypothetical future
where robots are replacing
coexisting with humans uh so major tone
shift coming and I'm just sitting down
to prepare all of you and now I'll go
back to the presentation
all right so we're going to start with
some contacts these are the failure
rates of iPhones
all right whenever we discuss failure
rates nobody is really going your Apple
is never going to put failure rates on
their website or in any of their
marketing presentations but I understand
this is very important to a lot of you
that buy the hardware it's very
important to me as well
um so to calibrate iPhone 6 is with the
worst and had a failure rate of about 26
percent uh whereas you got down to like
iPhone X's iPhone 8 plus and they were
like three percent right so the range
for iPhone failures is three percent to
26 percent
this is the real numbers right
um I could do it for game consoles too
but I like this chart for iPhones uh so
this was the failure rate of the Comet
two
uh yeah uh these are just real numbers
you know like I said we don't hire any
marketing or Communications people so we
don't have any people to make up fake
statistics to lie to you I just actually
took these screenshots from our real
okay how good is the hardware uh the
comment you failed a lot uh
you know look we honored the one-year
warranty spent a lot of money uh
honoring that one year warranty
uh and one of the biggest priorities for
the comma 3 was this cannot happen again
we are going to make these devices good
we did a lot better with comfort
uh
so you see orders of magnitude we've
shipped about
seven thousand six thousand which is a
lot better with the failure rate on the
three and the the real story is even
better than what that shows
um so this is the commentary failure
rates by month
and you can see a jump discontinuity
right here
it has nothing to do with one year or
anything like that
it has to do and that's when we move to
our new office
we built a real production facility for
these things
people think that this is easy people
think building like high-end Hardware
like this is easy go buy an owl cam and
you'll see that it has a crappy little
screen and it's in this like overly
dense plastic it doesn't look like a
sexy piece of modern consumer
electronics and it's because it's hard
right for however good you might think
our software is or however bad you might
think our software is our Hardware is
pretty much the same
all right same processes same ways of
thinking about things
um but we've put tons of effort into
making this a lot better
so you can see
the failure rates of modern comma threes
are a lot closer to five percent than
they are to nine
and we are going to do even better
we uh dropped the price five hundred
dollars
uh in January
you can see we two extra sales which is
nice
uh we do need a bit of growth uh so you
don't want too much growth right we're
not going to do we don't need to reach
the whole world this isn't for the whole
world but we do want to make a product
that is a bit more mass Market
quite a bit more mass Market
so where do we go from here
we'll find them
the comma 3 is great what do we do to
refine it
introduce them
the comma 3x
so it looks pretty much the same from
the front
uh
see the IR LEDs are a little different
this the case is so much better on the
3x like when we did the three it was the
first thing we injection molded and it
was bad
shiny black plastic
you know Igor's in the garage trying to
sand blast these things in our old
office oh come on like I look bad we
gotta makeup
stunning this time
um and you see the down curves there the
road cameras are on the board
we'll get to some pictures of the board
in a minute
now check time what Thomas
3x specs okay comma 3x
it's the same 845 platform and Camera
Arrangement as a three
so what this means is your three will
not become obsolete
um the three and the 3x are in the same
cohort meaning like the software is very
close to interchangeable between them
more similar to how like the Eon and the
Eon gold were in the same cohort
right like everything about the E on E
on gold we're similar enough that we
could keep the software supported at the
same time so we're not the three and the
three acts are pretty much the same
support window again no promises on this
but uh yeah
uh we upgraded the cameras
three Ox omnivision sensors uh these
sensors are newer generation they have
20 more DB of HDR they have a faster
rolling shutter they can operate at real
60 FPS if we wanted them to uh
yeah some of the late model coma threes
have this too so if you bought a comma 3
in the last couple months you have that
uh 128 gigabytes of storage versus 64
gigabytes uh so I put that star there
because we're going to start measuring
our gigabytes the same way phones do
some is taken up by the operating system
in the software but the real Flash on
the device is 128 gigabytes
so double the storage
can FD integrated
I I know this is the one people are
waiting for this is the one people were
asking about a Discord uh so so it
hasn't as great about panda
um same OLED uh same spec OLED in the
last five years the Chinese got good at
making oleds which is great so the comma
3 used a Samsung OLED it was really hard
to get the supplier was for anyone who
had a screen problem with the comma 3
they weren't all I don't even think all
the panels were new some of the wrinkle
ribbon cables came wrinkly and we did a
lot of filtering on them and it cost us
a lot of money now we have a new
supplier of the panels we put in an
order for a lot of them and when you put
in orders for lots of stuff you get
quality
um so yeah only panels uh same OLED
looks great
uh on board road cameras versus flaky
ribbon cables if any of you guys saw
camera see or Sierra or camera
malfunction uh the cameras are on the
board now and actually the CR Sierras
weren't even caused by the ribbon cables
they were caused by bad assembly
procedures uh which we fixed and
if we have time I can go into more
details on that
uh stereo in case sound
you guys saw the Hubble sphere video in
the comma 3 came out playing those
sounds it was bad uh those mono speakers
it wasn't well coupled to the case now
we designed something with two speakers
that are like coupled to the case it
uses gaskets it's nice
um the sound is good
uh upgraded power architecture how many
of you had to wait for like super caps
to flakily drain on the three maybe like
kind of half drain it's because the
super caps were connected directly to
the power rail now we have a boost
regulator in between the super caps and
the power rail which lets us get more
capacity out of them and never has this
weird thing where you're putting seven
volts into the comma
uh yeah
and about half the components
it's a lot more reliable
let's take a look at the board
this is the front
the front looks pretty similar to the
thread
a few things to know no more GPS
connector this is using the GPS that's
built into the quick towel
those little antennas are actually
better than the big antennas on the
three
you can see the pads for the speakers
you can see those connectors up in the
corner laser corner
this is not a laser cleaner
this is a laser pointer yeah as you can
see these connectors up here they're uh
the Wi-Fi Wi-Fi antennas on the board
uh yeah these LTE antennas are smaller
and better those are where the super
caps go they weren't soldered in for
this picture same two microphones
uh fan the GPS is using from the
quicktel we managed to get raw GPS out
of the quicktel the quality is the same
uh I mean it's limited to the antenna
uh yeah same psalm
where things really get good is on the
back I don't know if you've seen a
picture of the uh of the comma 3 back of
the circuit board
I will show one in the next slide uh
here you have the red panda integrated
in this tiny little chiplet
uh screen connects here power stuff all
underneath here to reduce noise GPS's
actually the GPS is better in this one
than the last one I think we got like 2
DB of noise lower
uh by shielding things and just doing a
better job with the with the power
architecture uh battery you guys don't
care about this but it slides in and out
so we don't have to hand solder it we
have to support can FD we have chokes on
all the can lines
uh you know like I paid three dollars
for this so I hope someone appreciates
it
um
uh these are the Wi-Fi antennas uh we
got a SIM card we tried with esim adiva
we'll uh talk to you about e-sims if you
want to know why maybe Sims of
but oh and then I guess the main thing I
really missed here is that the cameras
are right on the board
so the cameras are just just on the
board and part of the reason we can do
this and almost no one does this cell
phones don't do this
um is because we have uh
we have a lens focusing line in-house
right we can we can put the cameras on
the boards and focus the lenses
and we don't have to do modules right
less ribbon cables less noise more
reliability right this is how you make
things really really good
I want the reliability I want the
failure rate of this device to be like
one or two percent
and by the end I think we're going to
get there
uh so this is the common three board
compared to the 3x all right
uh which one of these do you think is
gonna break
right
uh
uh yeah
this is actually from we I couldn't find
this picture this is a screenshot of the
last YouTube so it's extra bad quality
oh we got rid of the nvme it just uses
the onboard onboard flash now uh again
it's enough
uh if you want more by Prime
uh we sort for you in the cloud or you
can set up your own Cloud Server if you
want to do that
uh QR codes on the board we like track
everything through this manufacturing
line
um it even looks reliable
is it a dev kit
I was on if I saw my latent space like
the guys were like comma didn't ship
anything because of some like spat with
the government or something and I'm like
this is like what year is it
we've had plenty of interactions with
Niche descents they were fine
like we report our accidents to
Nashville like it's it's fine it had
nothing to do with that the only reason
we called it a dev kit was to kind of
set expectations
I mean I don't know I think it's
probably time we stopped using that word
so it's just the comma 3x
it's Mass Market
I'm gonna sell a lot of these
I think this is it I mean I think this
is the one right like it's not is well I
guess you haven't gotten to really why
it's Mass market yet that's on the next
slide
all right so the comma 2 is 10.99.
with inflation
so what should we price it at
foreign
350.
12.50
no additions just 12.50 you know
something I realized doing this this is
what my seventh of these now uh is that
you are
uh he always gets so caught up in your
head with all these like oh we're gonna
name it the panda the pigeon the giraffe
oh man there's additions why does the
storage matter does the one terabyte
drive better what does cross country
mean
you know what guys you're hoping he'll
read the questions document
there's a great document about questions
I hate questions I hate when people ask
no you guys can ask questions it's cool
you guys paid to be here you pay you can
ask questions
um no but like people ask questions and
you know how you get rid of questions
you're just like well what does the one
edition do said no one ever right you
give them three editions they'll think
they have like a choice right it's just
it's not even like worth it like it's
just like it's 12.50 you can buy it and
I called it three stories because this
is a line
in uh
houses three stories
you know how you know this one's good
because the last one was good
it's just the comma three but better
everything about it is better and it's
cheaper
uh so when can you get one
order right now uh ships in one to two
weeks one to eight weeks one to eight
weeks uh one to eight weeks eight uh
depending on when you order if you order
right now you get the one
if you order
on Tuesday you get the four
if you order on next Wednesday after
like way after the Tuesday you get the
eight so you know order now uh
we have a pool in the office and I want
to win so I bet a high number so you
know
uh no they're they're really good
um this is this is the the three acts in
a in an EV sex uh no more red panda no
more two harnesses just five little
things stick it on it
you know you just you just look look
we're not on the 13th generation yet but
if you handed an iPhone 13 to somebody
in like 2007 like when did the iPhones
get good
you know what generation around what
number iPhone did they start getting
like wow okay this is just actually what
four five four five by the way is not
the fourth or fifth you know they did
they did three three Gs four fours
I hope we're kind of there right I hope
we're kind of the point where like this
one's good
um
yeah
that's my presentation
[Applause]
I also want to you know I didn't build
this I didn't build the software I
didn't build these models I didn't build
the hardware the team did
[Applause]
team apply for a job so apply for a job
by account with 3x you know it's a call
to action
uh no that I mean
look you know what judge the team after
buying a device and driving without
that's fair if it's good I didn't do it
if it's bad I did it so
the comma 3x is live on comma.ai
and now we're going to take some
questions
hello and thank you for presentation and
congratulations with 3x do you see any
value to run language models right on
device
uh why do you want to run a language
model
like interaction with
environment with driver
uh yeah sure
check it out it runs tiny grad it's
pretty good oh no our mission is to saw
self-driving cars with livingship with
intermediaries maybe solve robotics
while the living ship will
intermediaries if language models help
us do that we'll do it otherwise I don't
see a reason to but uh yeah no I think
you can totally get like llamas and
stuff to run probably not 7B but like
Little Llamas
a great great presentation uh I'm not a
developer uh I'm actually a marketing
guy so technically I'm a professional
liar uh I mean would you disagree with
that characterization no no that's what
we do uh
nothing personal obviously so I got some
uh just uh silly questions here so have
you done uh any testing or planning to
do any testing on commercial vehicles
like 18 wheelers and things like that
and that's why
why we've done a lot of testing this is
the best tested comma device by far are
we how many people we get in eppot
whole bunch of people been driving
around with these
we've made like 82 of them this is the
best tested one by far
um the the amount of I mean we control
so much of the stack now too we're we're
you'll hear about this in our next talk
but like we built out a a manufacturing
line and we tested them well have I done
any testing in 18 wheelers I don't have
an 18-wheeler I don't have I don't know
I have a motorcycle license I don't have
a CDL
Tesla partnered with Pepsi
how who's making money off this who's
this delivering value to like I don't
get it is this like someone want it's
not self-driving what do you mean you
got a driver in the seat this just
sounds expensive sorry just just one
more question so uh you know marketing
is branding and telling a good story
jobs sold good stories uh Elon sold good
stories until he bought Twitter uh
[Laughter]
so other than honest here what is the
story about open pilot that the common
person not developers need to know about
or want to be part of I I mean and this
is n't about kind of the lying and again
like what where I'm attacking this is
like what is open pilot open pilot is a
open source Adas system what is the
comma 3x it's Hardware that's capable of
running open pilot so you ask the
question what does the user need to know
just those two things and you can buy
them in our store for 12.50 right if
there's anything that's like the
narrative I mean it's exactly what I
said it's like you see you want you here
I'll show you the narrative I'll show
you the narrative in two words buy now
and you know what
you know what if you don't like it
here's another part of the narrative
30-day money-back guarantee
buy it try it
ships in one to eight weeks
hey George uh talk to us about how the
comma 3x will always be compatible with
the cars we drive and that the cars we
drive won't somehow disable the use of
the commas 3x
don't scan don't let Sam Altman scan
your eyeballs okay as long as you don't
do that I think you'll be good
I don't know what are they going to do
they're going to update the car this has
never happened like before maybe they're
gonna I don't think so oh I can't
promise you that I don't know man
probably not I've never seen it happen
you know what I mean
have to go there
uh hey there I was one of your hackathon
contestants
um look for my next hackathon project I
was curious
is it possible for a comma 3 to Port a
new model to a comma three
easy I mean it's tiny grad now so you
don't have to deal with smpe you can
just the Onyx support is pretty complete
in tiny grad uh yeah you can run
whatever you want
is it possible sure it doesn't say dev
kit anymore but it's still a dev kit
that's not a dev kit don't worry buy it
if you're worried about that word I
don't know man uh yeah but no you can
totally run other models on it it's not
that hard I don't know like again like
are we gonna do it no but you can do it
I mean I think we ran some I think we've
got like a YOLO running for the body
demo or something
where's the Tony FPS we've got YOLO
running 20 FPS
we can put boxes around things right we
love boxes
okay you're talking a lot about uh Mass
market right so but
I only have a C2 so forgive me if this
doesn't work this way MC3 but like you
get the device you turn it on you still
have to like download the software right
have you ever bought like a PS4 and had
to sit there while it updates for an
hour it's faster than that well so the
question is the PS4 Mass Market
but basically this is like a tiny
liability air gap right how do you feel
like this liability like is going to be
serving you in the future
like that that you said anything about
liability it's custom software I
explained to you what it was it has
nothing to do with liability and
everything to do with the fact that our
models are already chapped right right
and if it's rlhf that's a policy model
that's custom software the foundation
models will come on the device
right the foundation model is Tiny grad
agnos that comes on the device right
that's what the device is the software
the policy model that sits on top of it
that's custom software so in general
liability you're not concerned as far as
like future what do you mean Lions nhtsa
stuff like any of that I mean liability
I mean pay attention at all times it's
level two like the one comment I'd say
is like level three being shipped today
I'm not shipping level three level two
we'll ship level two percent
by the way we will cover the liability
if our car I'm not covering look
look
if you want to not pay attention
do not buy our product you must pay
attention at all times this is not a
joke this is not tongue-in-cheek you
must pay attention at all times we put a
lot of effort into making sure you pay
attention at all times every accident
I've ever seen with the comma device no
one's died no one's gotten seriously
injured and I've seen a few accidents
and every single one of them would have
prevent been prevented if people were
paying attention pay attention this is
not a joke this is not tongue-in-cheek
pay attention or don't buy the device
[Applause]
that said if you want to pay attention
it's a great device
hi great presentation and now as we saw
a large Foundation model
vocal per wheel do you think in the
future or near future the only very
powerful Hardware can power self-driving
car something like that yeah um so it's
a question so the commentary and the
comet reacts have an expansion Port they
have a USBC expansion Port that can do
full USBC bandwidth so we are capable of
streaming out the full sensorium device
um if it does turn out we do need to run
larger models which we haven't seen
better results with yet our
recommendation is going to be buy a
gaming laptop connect the gaming laptop
and put it under a seat
um no and I mean it like because it's
actually really hard to buy and video is
not going to sell you RTX
does 30 60s but you can go on Amazon and
for 8.99 you can buy an MSI plastic crap
gaming laptop stick it under seat it'll
run the model and actually I think we
can make the experience of this quite
good because if it loses connection to
the laptop it can fall back to the model
on device
um so with a lot of these things yes
more compute helps but model like
you can do all sorts of things where
your student teacher models to make it
smaller but are we going to need more
compute in the future of course we are
do we need more will more compute make
the comma device drive better right now
no
uh yeah also the other question is do
you have to can you can you do like
student teacher to put a small model on
the device that captures the policy
really well that's kind of where we're
going right now you'll hear more about
this in our next talk we're now training
a driving simulator
um and this is using a like an auto
encoder to compress the video and this
is a big model
um so we're training a big foundation
model but we may not necessarily need to
ship that to the device because what we
need to ship the device is a policy
model but we have Pathways I don't know
the exact answer are we going to need
more compute than what's on a comma 3
yes are we going to need it in the next
two years unclear probably not
thanks we've got a question upstairs
hey hey Josh uh sounds nice presentation
uh a few notes are first if you look at
those failure rates uh over time I think
there is like uh Spike if you look at it
then like summer times
so which suggests that you know they may
be
um
that isn't when the devices fail that's
when the device was built when it failed
right those failure rates are not that's
not the month the device failed that's
like when but anyways there is some
serious uh like um
time dependence that you might look at
but uh but my main question is not about
that actually it's a little bit to
reiterate and I really like uh the
effort you guys put into reliability of
3x
and I think it it should be actually
built uh even more reliables and like uh
your normal car because like if you look
at like human brain it's built like with
all like sorts of uh protections around
and that should be probably should come
up strive at like it should like really
build like a tank so even in the event
of collision it can record stuff and
like you know like the last yeah the
common device is not a safety device
it's not really it we don't know but but
just uh you don't use the word dash cam
anymore right like our goal again we're
a small company and like I said a lot of
what my job is now is saying no to
things right this is one of the last
things I still do from the company like
can we build all these fancy features no
we're not Tesla what we are trying to do
is build the best possible Highway and
Highway plus Driving Experience and you
can go on Reddit right now and see
people comparing autopilot to open pilot
you go back three years people would say
they were similar now
almost all of them are like look it's
cool with FSD and autopilot are doing
but day to day open pilot his hands down
better
um it was just a post on a comedy I
subreddit where some guy's talking about
he has two bolts one with supercruise
and one without yeah night and day this
is by far the best Ada system you can
buy and that's what we're focused on
doing right we start focusing on other
things the adap system gets worse right
everyone it's really easy to say yes to
things but it turns out it's saying no
that makes things really great
who has two bolts
some guy on Reddit I don't know man
I had an English teacher only had two
Nissan cubes
it's like that's my dad's I'm like the
car changed color he's like no that's my
dad's Nissan Cube and I'm like okay why
you'd buy one Nissan Cube you know
thanks to all the people who bought
comma 3x's already we're blowing up
George your high number make it hit yes
five in the first week
this is the first comma device that I
would recommend to like my friends I'd
be like this one's actually what have I
told my friends to buy an eon and a
giraffe and a panda like
you know what I'm saying they were all
good but some were better than others
this one's good
thanks everyone
oh my God